rütter shuttle-service jetzt gehen sie
und es kommt zu einem neue leute heute
zocken wir eine runde youtuber an muttis
erkennen und da habe ich mit zwei
besondere gäste eingeladen einmal zu
meiner rechten und zur linken seite
was heute passiert ist das folge
deutlich haben verschiedene käfer
gedacht die man gerade so in den kopf
gekommen sind und hab versucht das was
die so machen und wenn die so sind in
verschiedene images packen die kegler
erzählt und dann hörst du auf so dumm zu
und dann wenn die beiden versucht welche
youtube hinter sich der jeweilige
kombination verwirkt wir liegt jetzt los
der gewinner kriegt von mir als
spaghetti eis
was willst du porsche ag
ich zeige dir kommen jetzt noch mal in
ihren 32 erste youtube der gegner so
schnell wie wir es eigentlich schon klar
und ziemlich zeit über recht mega nah
beieinander auf dauer max war zu erst
angefangen
ja krass alter ich hier ganz fest wir
für euch nix konvention ist bereit und
betreibt man nicht so wie in dem 99
video berichtet aus
die trägt schon ab
echt gut bedienen kleine rote ist sie
[Musik]
das war schwer zu erraten kann sich der
wechsel youtube wird deutlich schwerer
ob es dann wirklich bisschen nachdenken
ja jetzt noch der krücke mit situation
nein kann man ein bisschen mehr an so ja
schon mal ganz genau dieses erste mode
gemacht so diese hochnehmen geste und
dann halt auto weil das range rover
mansory notwendig gefunden was geht
ich kann nicht mal wild gebaut die
kombination kommt hier richtig
funktion zu stören er wollte die zahl
nicht geredet mich nicht sehr gut
verpasste gesichert ich habe diese
[Musik]
situation kommt alles klar
leute wir haben auf jeden fall gerade
wenn ich sage wir auf jeden fall dran
weil wir auf jeden fall gerade hier
passiert wie das da hinten nicht ohne
ist dieser trend wird man als 38
wenn jemand nicht mag
[Musik]
alvaro mit dem was ihr seht ihr schon
manch einer kennt nicht mag es jetzt die
zeit ist für dich gekommen dass du dich
jetzt mal seitlich mental aktiv.de
missel mit rotkohl partie am 3 ja ich
dann endlich mal in ruhe halbwegs
überlegen müsste ich gelacht hat immer
so toll das ist so als würde man alle
machen und sagen ach so krank du kannst
es richtig gut
[Musik]
[Applaus]
viel spaß machen zu zu schauen was geht
das fabrikschiff